England does not look so different from Scotland. Aye, they are sisters.
Queen Elizabeth, your cousin Mary has returned to take up her throne in Scotland. The Queen!
My dear cousin Elizabeth,
I hope we might meet in person because I might embrace you but ruling side-by-side we must do so in
harmony
Not through a treaty drafted by men lesser than ourselves
My dear cousin let our nations cherish each other as we would. Two kingdoms united
How did the world come to this?... wise men servicing the whims of women?
Mary is our foe
We must never bow to her as we bow before you. You have the boldness to doubt my judgment!
She is only your queen if I should not produce an heir
What is it like? To have a man
With heaven's blessing
We bring an heir to Scotland and to England
It is a clear provocation.
We must make war in Scotland. So put your skills to use
Do not play into their hands. Our hatred is precisely what they hope for
I know your heart has more within it than the men who council you. You would do well to watch your words
I will not be scolded by my inferior
your inferior?...
Are you afraid, Henry?
No. Good, because our swords are not just for show
We have a scourge upon our land
There's a woman with a crown
Your beauty, your bravery... now I see there is no cause for envy
Your gifts will be your downfall
Should you murder me, remember you murder your sister and you murder your Queen.